looking at the diagram you can see that
we're achieving the exact same thing as
before but with less repeated code the
van and the cop functions produce the
same kinds of objects they always did
but they're allowing the car function to
do most of the work for them first but
in addition to providing a basis for the
van and the cop constructor functions
the car function is also a full-fledged
class itself if my code ever needed to
make simple car objects that lack the
more specific van and cop methods then
we could just call car directly and with
that we've completed our refactor to
include a superclass and two subclasses
interestingly the car class now looks
exactly the way the van class did before
we introduced the whole idea of cops
into our program